This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In one of the movie versions of the Oscar Wilde novel, the picture of Dorian Gray, the actor heard Hatfield stares longingly at a painting of himself. The picture shows a young man bursting with health and vitality, as Dorian Gray reflects on how he is going to change with age while his picture will stay the same. A strange wish passes through his head. Only the picture could change, and I could be always what I am now. For that I would give everything.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在奥斯卡·王尔德的小说《道林·格雷的画像》的某部电影版本中，演员海因茨·哈特菲尔德深情地凝视着一幅自己的肖像画。画面展现了一个充满健康与活力的年轻男子，道林·格雷则在思考自己将如何随着年龄的增长而改变，而他的画像却会保持原样。一个奇怪的愿望掠过他的脑海。只有画像会变，而我能永远保持现在的样子。为此我愿意付出一切。
There is nothing in the whole world I would not give. I would give myself a hand. In the story, Dorian Gray makes a pact with a devil. The painting starts to age in his place. The physical degradation of the picture isn't only about the passing years, the picture takes on the corruption of the characters many mistakes. Meanwhile, Dorian Gray himself stays eternally youthful. stays eternally youthful. Oscar Wilde wrote the story in the late 19th century. The movie came out in the middle of the 20th century.
为了这个，世界上没有我舍不得给的东西。我甚至愿意付出我的双手。在这个故事里，道林·格雷与魔鬼做了交易。画像开始替他变老。画作的身体衰败不仅关乎流逝的岁月中，画像还承担了他许多过失带来的腐化。与此同时，道林·格雷本人却永葆青春。却永葆青春。奥斯卡·王尔德在19世纪末写下了这个故事。这部电影则在20世纪中叶上映。
The 21st century is not that different in its preoccupations from its predecessors. Movies, TV shows and the fashion industry still worship at the altar of youth. People around the world spend billions of dollars on potions and injections and surgical interventions to keep the signs of age at bay. Clickbait ads on many websites show you what the youthful stars of yesterdays look like today. The message couldn't be clearer. Aging is a terrible thing. Growing old is a horror show.
21世纪的执念与前人并没有太大区别。电影、电视节目和时尚产业依然在膜拜青春的祭坛。世界各地的人们花费数十亿美元购买药水、注射剂和外科手术，来抵御衰老的迹象。许多网站上的点击诱饵广告向你展示着昔日的青春偶像如今的模样。这传达的信息再清楚不过了。衰老是一件可怕的事。变老简直是一场恐怖秀。
This week on Hidden Brain, astonishing new research about aging that could change the way everyone thinks about life. If you're short, you don't know what it feels like to be tall. If you're white, you won't know what it's like to be black. Lots of aspects of identity are like this. They are fixed. But there is one form of identity that is certain to change with time. Young people today will become old people tomorrow.
本周的《隐藏的大脑》节目将带来关于衰老的惊人新研究，它可能会改变所有人对生活的看法。如果你个子矮，你就不知道长得高是什么感觉。如果你是白人，你就不会知道身为黑人是什么体验。身份的许多方面都是如此。它们是固定的。但有一种身份注定会随着时间而改变。今天的年轻人明天就会成为老年人。
But while growing old is inevitable, it comes with so much psychological and cultural baggage that lots of us avoid thinking about it. In popular culture, getting old means getting kicked out. Lots of elderly people discover that aging makes them invisible to others. At Stanford University, psychologist Laura Carstensen has focused her attention on the topic of aging. She has discovered some astonishing things. Laura Carstensen, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. Pleasure to be with you. Laura, I want to take you back to 1974 when you were 21 years old. Like many young people on the Cusp of adulthood, you didn't give much thought to aging. What would you say your priorities were at this time of your life? My priorities were dating, exploring, and thinking
然而，尽管变老是不可避免的，但它承载了太多的心理和文化包袱，以至于我们许多人都在逃避思考它。在流行文化中，变老意味着被抛弃。许多老年人发现，衰老让他们在别人眼中变得隐形。在斯坦福大学，心理学家劳拉·卡斯滕森将注意力集中在了衰老这个话题上。她发现了一些令人惊奇的事情。劳拉·卡斯滕森，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。很高兴能来到这里。劳拉，我想带你回到1974年，那时你21岁。和许多正处于成年边缘的年轻人一样，你当时并没有过多地考虑衰老。你觉得你那时的生活首要任务是什么？我的首要任务是约会、探索，以及思考
about future jobs and possibilities and where I would live and what I was going to do the next day, the next week, the next year. Not a lot about my future. I didn't think at all about aging. Your life changed very dramatically one night that year. I understand that you and some friends were going to a concert. Tell me what happened, Laura. I worked as a waitress in a restaurant and a bunch of us after closing decided we would go to a concert. It was about an hour outside of town and we divided up into cars, drove out and we went to this concert. It was about an hour outside of town and we, you know, divided up into cars, drove
未来的工作、可能性、我将住在哪里，以及第二天、下周、明年我要做什么。对于未来并没有想太多。我根本没有想过衰老。那年的一天晚上，你的生活发生了急剧的变化。据我所悉，你和一些朋友当时正要去听一场音乐会。劳拉，告诉我发生了什么。我在一家餐馆当女服务员，打烊后我们一群人决定去听一场音乐会。离镇上大约有一个小时的车程，我们分乘几辆车，开出城去看了这场音乐会。离镇上大约有一个小时的车程，我们，你知道的，分乘几辆车，开
out and we went to this concert. At the end of the evening, we said, well, let's go back and play some pools. So we divided up again into different cars and started to head back to town. I happened to get in the car with a man I hardly knew who was very drunk and caught on to that pretty quickly and asked him to stop. I remember putting my hand out on the dashboard as he was going ever faster and that was the last thing I remembered before waking up in a ditch on the side of the road. He drove off the road and rolled down an embankment. The car turned two or three times over. And I broke about 20 plus bones, but my left leg was injured most badly.
了出去，去看这场音乐会。傍晚结束时，我们说，好吧，我们回去打会台球吧。于是我们再次分乘不同的车，开始回镇上。很不巧，我上了一个几乎不认识的男人的车，他喝得酩酊大醉，我很快就察觉到了并要求他停车。我记得当他越开越快时，我把手伸向了仪表盘，那是我在路边沟里醒来之前最后的记忆。他把车开出了路面，冲下了路基。车翻了两到三次。我断了大约20多根骨头，但我的左腿伤得最重。
My femur cracked in half, and I had many other fractures through the knee and the ankle. And I cracked ribs, I had concussion, lots of facial lacerations, lots and lots of injuries. I'm assuming there were a bunch of surgeries that must have followed this and sort of very intense hospitalization here. Yes. For the first couple of weeks, they couldn't do surgery because I had been injured so badly, they couldn't give me anesthesia. So those were the toughest two weeks. And then they began a surgery, but mostly they just kept my leg hanging in the air. It's that cartoonish image, you know, you have if someone laying in a hospital bed
我的股骨从中间裂开，膝盖和脚踝也有许多其他骨折。我的肋骨骨折了，脑震荡，脸上有很多撕裂伤，还有数不清的伤。我猜接下来一定有一连串的手术，而且住院治疗非常紧张。是的。最初的几个星期，他们无法为我做手术，因为我伤得太重，无法接受麻醉。所以那是艰难的两周。然后他们开始做手术，但大多数时候只是把我的腿吊在空中。就是那种漫画里才会出现的画面，你知道的，如果有人躺在病床上
and the leg is being held upwards and that would keep it somewhat straight. Was there a period in this window, Laura, where people were afraid that you might not make it? I mean, it sounds like this was a very, very serious crash. And the injuries were really serious. Yes. Certainly, there was the expectation that I may not make it. I remember at a point during that time, I wished I wouldn't make it. In hindsight, I remember thinking there are things worse than dying, but I kept sort of becoming unconscious but then coming out of it again in those early days and you know eventually started to heal. I'm wondering if your priorities changed around this time.
腿被高高吊起，这样能让它保持某种程度的直挺。劳拉，在这个期间，有没有一段时间大家担心你可能挺不过去了？我的意思是，听起来这是一场非常非常严重的车祸。而且伤情非常严重。是的。当然，当时确实有一种我可能挺不过去的预期。我记得那段时间里的某个时刻，我曾希望自己不要挺过去。事后回想起来，我记得当时想过，有些事情比死还要糟糕，但在那些日子里，我不断地失去意识，然后又清醒过来，你知道的，最终开始慢慢康复。我想知道你的首要任务是否在这期间发生了改变。
You know, you talked about how your priorities at age 21 were the priorities of anyone who was age 21. You're thinking about what's happening next week, next weekend. You know, maybe thinking about your dating life, you're thinking about what's happening next week, next weekend, you may be thinking about your dating life, you're thinking about your career, how did that worldview change as a result of the crash? I like many people who have these near death experiences completely changed how I thought about life. And suddenly life was something I didn't take for granted anymore. And life wasn't
你知道的，你谈到过自己在21岁时的首要任务和其他21岁的人一样。你在考虑下周、下周末会发生什么。你知道的，可能在想你的约会生活，你在考虑下周、下周末会发生什么，你可能在想你的约会生活，你在考虑你的职业，这种世界观是如何因这场车祸而改变的？就像许多经历过濒死体验的人一样，我彻底改变了对生活的看法。突然之间，生活不再是我理所当然拥有之物。生活不是
to be lived for fun and entertainment and exploration. I for the first time really saw how valuable time was. Laura's social world changed, too. A large circle of acquaintances was replaced by a bright spotlight on a small group of family and close friends. And for that I felt incredible gratitude to be surrounded by people who really cared about me and my parents came to visit, my siblings came to visit, my dad came every day. And I don't know what I would have done without that connection to the outside world and without the knowledge that I was embedded in a group of people who cared.
为了享乐、娱乐和探索而活的。我生平第一次真正看到了时间的价值。劳拉的社交世界也发生了改变。庞大的熟人圈子被缩小，聚光灯聚焦在了一小群家人和至交好友身上。为此，我感到难以置信的感激，身边都是真正关心我的人，我的父母来看望我，我的兄弟姐妹来看望我，我爸爸每天都来。我不知道如果没有与外部世界的这种联系，没有那种自己被一个充满关爱的群体包围的认知，我该怎么熬过去。
Tell me about your recovery. I understand that you were in the hospital for several months as you were recovering from these injuries. The way I remember this was about a month and a half before I thought about much of anything other than my injuries and how badly I had been hurt. But then I started to kind of wake up, if you will, and I started to get bored. It's a, when you lay flat on your back with your leg up in the air, strung up in the air, and there's just so much you can do day to day. And I got really bored. Laura's father, who was a professor, offered her a way out of her boredom. He had always wanted me to go to college.
跟我讲讲你的康复过程。据我了解，你在医院里度过了好几个月，一直在从这些伤痛中恢复。我的记忆是，大约有一个半月的时间，除了我的伤势以及我伤得有多重之外，我对其他任何事情都无暇顾及。但随后我开始“醒来”，如果你愿意这么说的话，我开始感到无聊。当你平躺着，腿被高高吊在空中，吊在半空中时，你一天能做的事情真的很有限。我真的觉得很无聊。劳拉的父亲是一名教授，他为她提供了一条摆脱无聊的出路。他一直希望我去上大学。
I had not gone to college up to that point. I was 21 in this accident. And he suggested when I complained about being bored that maybe I should take a course. And I was kind of resistant to it. And he said, really, just name a course and he would go tape the lectures and bring them to me. So I took introductory psychology
在那之前我没有上过大学。发生事故时我21岁。当我抱怨无聊时，他建议我或许可以修一门课程。我当时有点排斥。他说，真的，随便说一门课，他去把讲课内容录音带给我。于是我选修了心理学导论
as a hospital patient laying flat on my back with my leg tied in the air. Wait, so your dad actually sat in the psychology classes and recorded them and brought you back the cassettes to listen to? My dad was a saint. Yes. My dad was a biophysicist by the way and when he first asked me what I wanted to take, I was like saying, oh, not physics.
作为一名平躺在病床上、腿被绑在空中的住院病人。等等，所以你爸爸实际上坐在心理学课堂上把课录下来，然后带回磁带给你听？我爸爸是个圣人。是的。顺便说一句，我爸爸是一位生物物理学家，当他第一次问我想学什么时，我说，哦，千万别选物理。
And he said, no, anything, anything. And so, yes, he went to every lecture of introductory psychology with a tape recorder. And tape recorded the lectures and brought them to me in the hospital. Wow. Yeah. Yeah. So, while you were in the hospital, the nurses assigned you a task, which was also in some ways perhaps a psychology workshop of talking with some of the elderly patients who were in the same ward as you.
他说，不，什么都行，什么都行。所以，是的，他带着录音机去听了心理学导论的每一堂课。把讲座录下来，带到医院给我听。哇。是啊。是啊。所以，当你在医院时，护士给你分派了一项任务，某种程度上这也是一个心理学工作坊，那就是与同病房的一些老年患者聊天。
Why did they ask you to do that, Laura? Well, I had gotten to know the nurses. Again, you're with the same people day after day, and so we had begun to talk a little bit, and I complained to them about being bored, and they said, we've got an assignment for you. There are a lot of older women who come into the orthopedic ward, and we're're gonna put them in this room with you. I was on a four bed ward. And your job is to talk to them and keep them alert and so they don't get confused and so on.
劳拉，他们为什么让你这么做？嗯，我已经和护士们很熟了。同样，你日复一日地和同样的人在一起，所以我们开始聊了起来，我向他们抱怨无聊，他们说，我们给你派了个任务。有很多老年妇女住进骨科病房，我们要把她们安排和你一个房间。我住的是四人病房。你的工作是和她们聊天，让她们保持清醒，这样她们就不会神志不清等等。
So we're giving you that job. So two things happened. One, I'm taking introductory psychology and the second one is I've now been assigned to talk to older women. Hmm. Now, I can't tell whether this is a psychological intervention to help you or a psychological intervention
所以我们把这个工作交给你。于是发生了两件事。第一，我在上心理学导论；第二，我现在的任务是和老年妇女聊天。嗯。现在，我分不清这究竟是对你的心理干预，还是对你交谈对象的心理干预
to help the people you were talking with, but perhaps it was both at the same time. Well, really, this was about helping me. They were trying to give me a gift of a job. They were trying to give me a gift of a job. Is there anything you glean from your time spent, from the time you spent with these elderly patients in the ward? So many things. I learned so much from this experience about aging.
，或许这两者同时存在。嗯，说实话，这主要是为了帮我。他们是想送我一份工作当礼物。他们是想送我一份工作当礼物。从你度过的那段时间里，从你和病房这些老年患者相处的时间里，你有什么收获吗？有太多东西了。我从这次经历中学到了很多关于衰老的知识。
For one, their lives were so different from one another. And their personalities and their outlooks on life For one, their lives were so different from one another. And their personalities and their outlooks on life were so different from one another. That to the extent that I had stereotypes about what older people were like, they went quite far in challenging those stereotypes. One woman that I shared a room with was a matriarch
首先，她们的生活彼此大不相同。她们的性格和人生观首先，她们的生活彼此大不相同。她们的性格和人生观也彼此大不相同。以至于我原本对老年人有什么刻板印象的话，这些经历在很大程度上挑战了这些刻板印象。我同屋的一位女士是她
of her family family and these young kids would come in and sit on the bed and talk to her. There were other women who were really sad, really in a tough situation. I remember one woman in the hospital room who had to sell her home in order to pay the hospital bill before they would discharge her and so she had to be transferred to a nursing home instead of back to her own home and it was all for financial reasons. There was another woman who just kind of laid in her bed and stared at the ceiling all day and you know the physicians would come in they'd surround my bed they'd be trying to
家族的大家长，这些小年轻会进来坐在床边和她聊天。还有其他一些女士真的很伤心，处境真的很艰难。我记得病房里有一位女士，为了支付住院费，不得不卖掉自己的房子，然后才能出院，所以她不得不被转到一个疗养院，而不是回自己的家，这一切都是出于财务原因。还有一位女士只是躺在床上，整天盯着天花板，你知道的，医生们会走进来，围着我的床，试图
do all sorts of things to help rehabilitate me, get me better, thinking about my future. And then they would just wave to her on the way out the door, say, hey, Sadie, just keep going. They didn't pay much attention to her at all. There was another insight I had from spending so much time with these older women who were also spending all their days in bed, being cared for by other people. And that insight was just how much we had in common.
做各种各样的事情来帮助我康复，让我好起来，为我的未来着想。然后在出门的路上，他们只是对她挥挥手，说，嘿，赛迪，坚持下去。他们根本没有给予她多少关注。从与这些同样整天躺在床上、由他人照顾的老年女性相处的经历中，我得到了另一个深刻见解。那个见解就是我们之间竟然有如此多的共同点。
So I was 21 and these women were, you know, in their 70s and 80s and probably 90s. But we were all dependent on other people for everything from, you know, being fed to staying clean, to having any social interaction. I mean, everything we were dependent on. So suddenly, I shared these characteristics that I would have thought of as characteristics of old people,
所以当时我21岁，而这些女性已经70多、80多，可能还有90多岁了。但我们在方方面面都依赖着其他人，从（你知道的）喂食、保持清洁，到进行任何社交互动。我的意思是，一切我们都得依赖别人。所以突然之间，我拥有了这些我本以为是老年人特征的属性，
or sick people, but now it was me too. And so that also changed. And it made me think about the world and how the world comes to shape who we are. And the one insight I had about aging, or at least was at the beginnings of my thinking about aging, was that aging is a biological process, but it's driven, shaped by the social world.
或是病人的特征，但现在这也成了我的一部分。所以这同样发生了改变。它让我开始思考世界，以及世界是如何塑造我们成为什么样的人的。我关于衰老的一个见解，或者说至少是我开始思考衰老的开端，那就是衰老是一个生物学过程，但它是由社会世界所驱动、所塑造的。
And that was the insight that led me to be interested in the science of aging. Laura spent four months in the hospital. After she was discharged, she was in a wheelchair for a while and then walked with a cane for several years after that. and then walked with a cane for several years after that. While she gradually recovered from her injuries, the hospital experience stayed with her. She finished college, went to graduate school, and decided to become a researcher who studies the science of aging. She was soon to discover a phenomenon that affects not just the elderly, but everyone at every stage of life. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
正是这个见解让我对衰老科学产生了兴趣。劳拉在医院住了四个月。出院后，她坐了一段时间轮椅，之后的几年里一直靠拐杖走路。之后的几年里一直靠拐杖走路。在逐渐从伤痛中康复的同时，这段住院经历一直伴随着她。她完成了大学学业，进入研究生院，并决定成为一名研究衰老科学的研究员。不久后，她将发现一个不仅影响老年人、而且影响每个生命阶段所有人的现象。广告回来后，我们为您揭晓。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Laura Carstensen is a psychologist at Stanford University. She's the founding director of the Stanford Center on Longevity. When she was a young woman, she sustained some serious injuries in a car crash. As she recovered in the hospital, she found herself surrounded by elderly patients with many informaties. The experience helped her decide to specialize in the science of aging. Laura, when you started your career
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。劳拉·卡斯滕森是斯坦福大学的心理学家。她是斯坦福长寿研究中心的创始主任。年轻时，她在一次车祸中受了重伤。在医院康复期间，她发现自己被许多身患各种疾病的老年患者所包围。这段经历促使她决定专注于衰老科学的研究。劳拉，当你开启职业生涯时
as a psychologist in the early 1980s, there was a scientific consensus about what it meant to grow old. Was it fair to say that that consensus was a grim one? Oh, it was grim indeed. Aging was considered to be a serious threat to virtually everyone's mental health. There was a clinical psychology textbook that I had when I was in graduate school. So this was a textbook on psychopathology.
作为20世纪80年代初的一名心理学家，当时科学界对变老意味着什么有着一种共识。这种共识可以说是一种惨淡的共识吗？哦，确实非常惨淡。人们认为衰老对几乎所有人的心理健康都是严重的威胁。我读研究生时有一本临床心理学教科书。这是一本关于精神病理学的教科书。
They had a chapter on anxiety, a chapter on depression, a chapter on drug abuse, and then they end a chapter on old age. So old age itself was considered pathological. And I'm assuming that when scientists were talking about the pathologies of old age, they were referring to things like declines in cognitive function, impairments in memory, depression, anxiety, a whole range of problems.
里面有一章讲焦虑，一章讲抑郁，一章讲药物滥用，然后最后一章讲老年。所以老年本身就被认为是一种病理状态。我猜，当科学家们在讨论老年的病理变化时，他们指的是诸如认知功能下降、记忆力受损、抑郁、焦虑以及一系列的问题。
The whole range. And you know, at the time, people also believed that Alzheimer's disease was the inevitable consequence of aging. So that cognitive impairment would begin and would eventually progress to dementia, so that that was the fate of people who lived very long lives. So soon after you started working as an academic, the National Institute of Mental Health funded a study to assess the prevalence of psychiatric disorders. What did it find and what was its impact on your Laura? Yes, this was an epidemiological catchment area study of mental health, conducted in
全方位的。而且你知道，当时人们还认为阿尔茨海默病是衰老的必然结果。认知障碍会开始并最终发展为痴呆，这就是那些长寿之人的命运。因此，在你开始从事学术工作后不久，美国国家心理健康研究所资助了一项研究，旨在评估精神疾病的患病率。它发现了什么？这对你的劳拉有什么影响？是的，这是一项关于心理健康的流行病学集水区研究，进行于
the early 1980s, and it was not a study designed about old age at all. It was a study that was designed so that the researchers could get a better estimate of different forms of psychopathology in the community. And so what they did was to have trained clinicians go out into the communities and interview a representative sample of people in a number of different geographical areas around the country. So it was, it was the best epidemiological study of mental health that had been done in this country, probably anywhere at the time. The results of it were to give them pretty good estimates of the prevalence of
20世纪80年代初，它根本不是一项关于老年的研究。这项研究旨在让研究人员更好地估计社区中不同形式的精神病理学。因此，他们让训练有素的临床医生深入社区，采访全国多个不同地理区域的具有代表性的人群样本。因此，它是当时在这个国家、甚至可能在任何地方所做过的最好的心理健康流行病学研究。其结果为他们提供了相当不错的关于以下病症患病率的估计
anxiety, depression, bobias, etc., etc. And one of the findings that was embedded in this set of findings about prevalence was that the prevalence of every form of psychopathology with the exception of the dimensions was observed at lower rates and older people than middle aged or younger people. And this really turned on its head the idea that psychopathology, mental health problems, depression, anxiety, were part and parcel of growing old. The National Institute of Mental Health Study was studying emotions associated with psychiatric
焦虑、抑郁、恐惧症等，等等。在这组关于患病率的发现中，其中一个发现是，除痴呆症外，各种形式的精神病理学的发病率在老年人中比在中年人或年轻人中更低。这彻底颠覆了这种观念：精神病理学、心理健康问题、抑郁、焦虑是变老不可分割的一部分。美国国家心理健康研究所的研究当时正在研究与精神疾病相关的情绪。
disorders. Laura wanted to broaden the picture. What were the everyday emotions experienced by people who were young, middle aged, and elderly? To find out, she ran a study that measured the daily emotions of people ranging in age from 18 to 94. We studied a whole range of positive emotions and negative emotions. We wanted to understand what emotional experience
劳拉想要拓宽视野。年轻人、中年人和老年人每天体验到的日常情绪是什么样的？为了弄清这一点，她开展了一项研究，测量了年龄从18岁到94岁的人的日常情绪。我们研究了一系列积极情绪和消极情绪。我们想要了解日常生活中的情绪体验
in day-to-day life was like. So we knew from this large study of mental health problems that they had lower rates of that, but we didn't know a lot about what day-to-day emotional life was like an old age. And so at the time we designed a study using what was then the gold standard, probably still is, of studying emotional experience in day- day to day life. And we gave people pages, electronic pages, and they carried them for a week. And at random times, during each of seven days, we paged them and asked them to tell us the extent to which they were feeling each of 19 different emotions. Some were positive emotions like joy, happiness, calm, some were negative
究竟是怎样的。因此，从这项关于心理健康问题的大型研究中，我们知道他们的发病率较低，但我们对老年人日常情绪生活了解不多。因此，当时我们设计了一项研究，采用了当时（可能现在依然是）研究日常生活中情绪体验的黄金标准。我们发给人们寻呼机，电子寻呼机，他们随身携带了一个星期。在七天里每天的随机时间，我们呼叫他们，让他们告诉我们他们感受到19种不同情绪的程度。有些是积极情绪，如快乐、幸福、平静，有些则是消极
emotions like anger, sadness, fear. And so we had this detailed record now for individuals about their emotional lives. So the NIMH study was finding that older people, in fact, were not suffering from higher levels of psychopathology. You were studying, if you will, more ordinary emotions, everyday emotions. What did you find in terms of the everyday emotions of the young, the middle aged, and the elderly? We found that increasingly older people had fewer negative emotions, less anger reported, less fear, less disgust,
情绪，如愤怒、悲伤、恐惧。于是我们现在有了关于个人情绪生活的详细记录。因此，美国国家心理健康研究所的研究发现，事实上，老年人并没有遭受更高水平的精神病理学困扰。如果你愿意的话，你当时正在研究更普通的情绪、日常情绪。在年轻人、中年人和老年人的日常情绪方面，你发现了什么？我们发现，随着年龄的增长，老年人往往会有更少的负面情绪，报告的愤怒更少、恐惧更少、厌恶更少，
and just as much happiness joy calm. And so this was consistent with these findings about psychopathology as well, right? Now we had a normal healthy population from the community, and we were observing something similar. Now, it must have felt a bit like a head scratch or given all that we had heard about how aging is a horror show, did you ever worry that you had something wrong in the data? It wasn't just us who worried about it. It was the whole field that was in disbelief. So the general public kind of didn't buy it. More importantly,
而快乐、喜悦和平静却一样不少。所以这与关于精神病理学的这些发掘是一致的，对吧？现在我们有了一个来自社区的正常健康人群，我们观察到了类似的情况。现在，鉴于我们听到的所有关于衰老是一场恐怖秀的说法，这一定让人觉得有点匪夷所思，你有没有担心过你的数据出了什么问题？不仅是我们担心这个问题。整个领域都对此感到难以置信。因此，普通大众有点不太买账。更重要的是，
the scientific community was very eager to scrutinize these findings and figure out what was wrong. And in science, nothing better can happen than that. Having a finding that, you know, lots of other laboratories, lots of other investigators say, I don't quite believe it, I'm gonna look at it this way. Maybe X explains it, maybe Y explains it. So there was one alternative that people were reporting that they were happy because they didn't have the cognitive ability to really ruminate and generate lots of negative emotions.
科学界非常渴望仔细审视这些发现，并找出问题所在。在科学界，没有什么比这更好的事情了。有一个发现，你知道的，许多其他实验室、许多其他研究人员说，“我不太相信，我要从这个角度来看看。也许X可以解释它，也许Y可以解释它。”因此，当时人们报告了一种替代解释，即他们感到快乐是因为他们没有认知能力去真正反刍并产生大量的消极情绪。
If you can't remember how upset you were yesterday and how people treated you, to be able to do that. I think that's a very, very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing.
如果你记不住昨天自己有多沮丧，别人是怎么对待你的，你就无法做到这一点。我认为这是一件非常非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。
I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing.
我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。
I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. I think that's a very important thing. as the village idiot of hypothesis. You know, it's just kind of like, if you really can't appreciate just how bad your circumstances are, why, you know, you're happy. Lots of studies have looked at the relationship between everything from executive functioning and education to intelligence and this positive outlook on life.
我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。就像是假说中的村里傻子一样。你知道的，这就像是，如果你真的无法体会到你的处境有多糟糕，为什么，你知道的，你会感到快乐。许多研究探讨了从执行功能、教育到智力与这种积极生活观之间的关系。
And it's the reverse. So people with the highest levels of executive function and cognitive abilities and education, those are the ones showing this effect, the strongest, so we ruled that one out. Then there was a hypothesis generated by many in the field of psychiatry that was called masked depression. That is, really older people were terribly depressed, but they were covering that up because it was a way of keeping it from others, but more importantly, fooling themselves.
结果恰恰相反。因此，具有最高水平执行功能、认知能力和教育水平的人，正是表现出这种效应最强烈的人，所以我们排除了这种可能性。然后，精神病学领域的许多人提出了一个名为“掩蔽性抑郁”的假设。也就是说，实际上老年人非常沮丧，但他们掩盖了这一点，因为这是一种防止别人发现的方法，更重要的是，这是一种欺骗他们自己的方法。
So we did studies and others did studies where we would have people experience different kinds of emotions while they were in brain scanners and be able to look at activation of different regions of the brain. And again, you couldn't explain it through a lack of activation. And a lot of research was done to try to explain or reconcile that this was really just cognitive impairment or brain impairment. it was really about something else, but with every study it became clear
因此，我们和其他人开展了研究，让人们在脑部扫描仪中体验不同种类的情绪，并能够观察大脑不同区域的激活情况。同样，你无法用缺乏激活来解释这一点。人们进行了大量的研究，试图解释或调和这其实只是认知障碍或大脑损伤，
that this was a highly reliable finding. Older people were happier in their day-to-day lives on balance than younger people were. So eventually the weight of all this evidence convinced even the skeptics and the finding that older people were in fact happier than younger people was dubbed the paradox of aging. What was the paradox, Laura? Well the paradox really was that aging entails a lot of bad things.
这其实是关于其他事情的，但随着每一项研究的深入，情况变得越来越明朗：这是一个高度可靠的发现。总体而言，老年人在日常生活中比年轻人更快乐。因此，最终所有这些证据的分量连怀疑论者都被说服了，而老年人实际上比年轻人更快乐这一发现被称为“衰老悖论”。劳拉，什么是悖论？嗯，悖论实际上在于衰老伴随着很多糟糕的事情。
You know, cognitively people often do change, feel, that memory isn't as good, attention is tougher to keep in focus, not to mention the physical changes with age. Most of us experience more aches and pains. So all these things are changing. And then we're in the societal context. People aren't taking us as seriously as they used to. There's an invisibility people talk about when they get old that people walk almost right through
你知道的，在认知上人们确实会发生变化，觉得记忆力不如以前了，注意力更难集中，更不用说随着年龄增长带来的身体变化了。我们大多数人经历了更多的病痛。所以所有这些事情都在改变。然后我们身处社会环境中。人们不像以前那样认真对待我们了。人们谈论变老时有一种隐形感，仿佛人们几乎直接从他们
them and they're just not noticed. And so if all of that's happening with aging and there it is, how could it be that older people are emotionally doing well? I mean, and it does seem like a mystery because of course, social status, physical health, friendship networks can become more limited, social engagement can decline. And you would think that if all those things happen, if you had less social status, less physical health, a smaller network, less levels, lower levels of social engagement, you would predict that the people would then have worse psychological health and yet psychological well-being seemed
身边走过却根本注意不到他们。因此，如果所有这些事情都随着衰老而发生，事实就是如此，为什么老年人在情感上还能过得很好呢？我的意思是，这确实看起来像个谜，因为当然，社会地位、身体健康、朋友圈子可能会变得更有限，社交参与度可能会下降。你会认为，如果所有这些事情都发生了，如果你拥有更低的社会地位、更差的身体健康、更小的网络、更低水平的社交参与度，你会预测人们的心理健康会更糟，然而心理健康状况似乎
to be improving. Yeah, it challenged all of our basic assumptions about what gives us happiness, right? It's having a lot of friends. It's having a bright future. The older we get, the closer we are to death, you know, how could it possibly be that people get happier? So as you were trying to tease apart this mystery, in some ways, the fact that the data coming in was so at odds with intuitions and cultural beliefs that many people had about aging,
在不断改善。是的，它挑战了我们关于什么带给我们幸福的所有基本假设，对吧？是拥有很多朋友。是拥有光明的未来。我们越老，距离死亡越近，你知道的，人们怎么可能变得更快乐呢？因此，当你试图解开这个谜团时，在某种程度上，源源不断的数据与许多人对衰老的直觉和文化信仰如此相悖
you stumbled on an answer to that mystery one day as you were interviewing a pair of elderly siblings, Laura. Yes. One day I interviewed two sisters who lived together in an apartment in San Francisco. It was an apartment that housed a lot of older people. And they were talking to me about how sad they were that they had lost many good friends and relatives as they had gotten older. And I said to them, oh, what about new friends? There are a lot of people who live here in this building and you reach out to them, you want to make new friends. And I remember them giving me this kind of blank stare like you just don't get it.
，以至于有一天你在采访一对老年兄妹时，无意中找到了这个谜团的答案，劳拉。是的。有一天，我采访了住在旧金山一间公寓里的两姐妹。那是一栋住着很多老人的公寓。她们跟我谈起，随着年龄的增长，她们失去了许多好朋友和亲戚，对此她们感到多么难过。我对她们说：“哦，那新朋友呢？这栋楼里住了很多人，你们去接触他们，难道不想结交新朋友吗？”我记得她们给了我那种空白的眼神，就像你根本不懂一样。
And they said, Laura, we don't have time for those people. And I looked at them and first thought, you don't have time? Come on, you've got a lot of time on your hands, don't you? And then I went away and they were kind enough to send me off and be sweet to me. But I went home and I remember sitting at my dining room table staring out at the San Francisco skyline. And it was this moment where I feel like I had kind of an epiphany where I said, it's about time. And I realized that it wasn't about time in the day,
她们说：“劳拉，我们可没时间理这些人。”我看着她们，脑子里闪过的第一个念头是：你们没时间？拜托，你们手头有的是时间，不是吗？然后我离开了，她们很友善地送我出门，对我很好。但我回到家，我记得自己坐在饭厅的桌旁，凝视着旧金山市的天际线。就在那一刻，我仿佛有了一种顿悟，我说：“这关乎时间。”我意识到这并不是指一天中的时间，
it was about time left in life. And if our time horizons are changing, if they're getting shorter as we grow older that our goals made systematically change. And everything in my life and my research changed after that evening. Laura's epiphany was quickly followed by a second moment of insight. She realized her own life contained a case study of the very phenomenon the elderly siblings had demonstrated to her.
这关乎生命中剩余的时间。如果我们对时间的展望发生变化，随着年龄增长，时间变得越来越短，我们的目标就会系统性地改变。那一晚之后，我生活中的一切以及我的研究都改变了。劳拉的顿悟很快迎来了第二个灵光一现的时刻。她意识到，她自己的生活本身就包含了一个案例研究，正是那几位年长兄姐向她展示过的那种现象。
She thought back to the time she had come close to dying at the age of 21. She remembered how her priorities, her social world, had changed dramatically. I didn't know that I was going to make it through those months of recuperating and the idea of exploring this very large world full of possibilities was of no interest to me either during that time. But I did care about things. It wasn't a flattening of emotions. It was a very sharp focus of what matters and what doesn't.
她回想起自己21岁时险些丧命的经历。她记得自己的优先级和社交世界是如何发生剧烈变化的。“我不知道自己能否挺过那些康复的月份，而且在那段时期，探索这个充满无限可能、无比广阔的世界对我来说也毫无兴趣。但我确实在意一些事情。这并不是情感的扁平化，而是对什么重要、什么不重要的一种极其敏锐的聚焦。”
And it's very much tied to time, time left. When we come back, the powerful force that shapes us throughout our lives from youth to old age. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. them. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Laura Karstensen is a psychologist at Stanford University.
这在很大程度上与时间息息相关，也就是剩余的时间。稍后回来，我们将探讨从青年到老年，这一塑造了我们一生的强大力量。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这就是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。劳拉·卡斯滕森是斯坦福大学的心理学家。
She's the author of a long, bright future, happiness, health and financial security in an age of increased longevity. While conducting research on the surprising emotional resilience of elderly people, Laura identified a powerful subterranean force that was shaping the outlook of the individual she studied. This force had to do with how people of different ages and people at different life stages perceive the amount of time they have left in their lives.
她是《漫长而光明的未来：长寿时代的幸福、健康与财务安全》一书的作者。在对老年人惊人的情绪韧性进行研究时，劳拉发现了一种强大的潜伏力量，正是这种力量塑造了她所研究的个体的世界观。这种力量与不同年龄段的人以及处于不同人生阶段的人如何看待他们生命中剩余的时间有关。
Humans, to the best of our knowledge, are the only species that appreciates our mortality throughout most of our lives. So there are other species like elephants, lions, they probably know when they are dying. But we anticipate how much time we have left throughout the course of our lives. And we do this subconsciously most of the time. And then every once in a while events occur that prime mortality, it could be the death
据我们所知，人类是唯一在生命的绝大部分时间里都能意识到自身终有一死的物种。虽然还有其他物种，比如大象、狮子，它们可能知道自己何时将死，但我们在整个生命历程中都会预知自己还剩多少时间。而且在大多数时候，我们都是在潜意识中这样做的。然后，偶尔会发生一些事件来唤醒死亡意识，这可能是一个朋友的离世
of a friend or a terrorist attack, you know, a war, something happens that reminds us that we're mortal and we're not going to live forever. We don't have all the time in the world. And as we get older, we increasingly experience those kinds of reminders. And so we come to take account of time and value time differently. Goals change systematically as our time horizons change. So let's delve into that with a little more detail. When we are younger, take for example the undergraduates that you're teaching at Stanford. Obviously they are young people, they have their entire lives in front of them. What are that time horizons?
或是恐怖袭击，你知道的，一场战争，总有什么事情发生，提醒我们终有一死，我们不会长生不老。我们并没有拥有世间所有的无限时间。随着我们变老，我们越来越频繁地经历这类提醒。因此，我们开始审视时间，并以不同的方式看待时间的价值。随着我们的时间视野发生变化，目标也会系统性地改变。那么，让我们更详细地探讨这一点。当我们更年轻时，以你在斯坦福教的本科生为例。显然他们很年轻，他们的人生还很长。他们的时间视野是怎样的？
And how does it affect how they're thinking, Laura? It's an interesting question, because when we began this, we thought younger people think about their futures a lot, and they envision their futures is very, very long. It turns out the more we've studied this, that a clear answer, more accurate answer, is that younger people don't think there are any constraints on time.
这又如何影响他们的思考方式呢，劳拉？这是一个有趣的问题，因为当我们开始这项研究时，我们以为年轻人会花很多时间思考他们的未来，并且他们设想的未来是非常非常漫长的。事实证明，随着我们对此研究得越多，一个清晰且更准确的答案是，年轻人并不认为时间受到任何限制。
So they don't think about the future so much in terms of how much left there is. It's that it's just vast, it's abundant. They don't need to think about time. And it's really the shift as we grow older, where we come to think about time more, how much time we have left. But for young people, they have all the time
所以他们思考未来时，并不怎么考虑还剩多少时间。而是觉得时间浩瀚无垠、取之不竭。他们不需要去思考时间。真正发生转变的是在我们变老的过程中，我们会开始更多地思考时间，思考我们还剩多少时间。但对于年轻人来说，他们基本上拥有世上
in the world, essentially. So as we get older, the shifting time horizon has a number of different kinds of effects on our lives and our choices. We talked briefly about this before, but one of the effects is on our social relationships. What is the effect of our shrinking time horizons on our social relationships, Laura? Social networks get smaller as people get older. And I should note that this was part of the thinking about the paradox of aging. You know, because social relationships are what bring us our greatest happiness, there was thinking that if networks and older people were smaller than they were in younger people,
所有的时间。因此，随着我们变老，这种不断变化的时间视野会对我们的生活和选择产生多种不同的影响。我们之前简要讨论过这一点，但其中一个影响就体现在我们的社会关系上。劳拉，我们缩短的时间视野对社会关系有什么影响？随着人们年龄的增长，社交网络会变小。我应该指出，这是关于衰老悖论的思考的一部分。你知道的，因为社会关系给我们带来最大的幸福，所以曾有一种观点认为，如果老年人的社交网络比年轻人更小，
then older people must not be as happy. That was basically the thinking. Instead, it appears that what happens is that over time, social networks get smaller, but they're very well honed. And so the people who are retained in the networks are those that are most important. The people who are most predictable, most valuable in our lives.
那么老年人一定就没有那么快乐。这基本上是当时的看法。然而事实似乎是，随着时间的推移，社交网络虽然变小了，但它们经过了精心的打磨。因此，网络中保留下来的人都是最重要的人。也就是我们生活中最可预测、最有价值的人。
And those are the relationships that stay. And we let these other more distant acquaintance like relationships fade away. But what it means in is that our social networks, as we get older, are more emotionally dense. They're people who we really care about. And so there's a real benefit to that kind of a social network. You know, there are so many jokes about how the elderly are incurious. They're stuck in their ways.
正是这些关系得以保留。而我们让其他那些泛泛之交般的关系逐渐淡去。但这其中的意义在于，随着年龄增长，我们的社交网络在情感上更加紧密厚重。网络里都是我们真正关怀的人。因此，这种社交网络有着真正的益处。你知道，有太多关于老年人因循守旧、固执己见的笑话了。
You know, you can't teach an old dog new tricks. But party what I'm hearing you say is that the old dogs' old tricks are actually pretty good. Yeah. The old dog is pretty happy with those tricks. Exactly. I try to explain this to undergraduates who are having a hard time grasping that. Like, I say, imagine that you only had one week left
你知道，江山易改，本性难移。但从某种程度上说，我听到你的意思是，老家伙们的那些老把戏其实挺不错的。是的。老家伙对那些把戏感到挺满意的。完全正确。我试图向那些难以理解这一点的本科生解释这一点。比如，我会说，想象一下你只剩下一周时间了
in a city that you'd been exploring. Do you want to try another new restaurant or do you want to go to your favorite restaurant in that last time out? And I think that's some of what's happening with age. Exploration is extremely adaptive when time horizons are long. We need to learn, we need to explore, we need to collect
在一个你一直在探索的城市里。你是想尝试另一家新餐厅，还是想去上一次你最喜欢的餐厅？我认为这就是随年龄增长而发生的一些变化。当时间视野漫长时，探索具有极高的适应性。我们需要学习，我们需要探索，我们需要收集
because those kinds of things could be useful. And especially if your time horizon is so vast, right? Anything could happen. So meeting somebody at a party, even somebody you may not particularly like, could end up being an important contact five years from now when you're looking for a job. So people are collecting and they're very open to that. But as time horizons are shorter, we focus. We focus, we savor, we see better what's important and what's not.
因为这类事情可能会派上用场。特别是如果你的时间视野非常广阔，对吧？任何事情都有可能发生。所以在派对上遇到某人，甚至是一个你可能并不是特别喜欢的人，五年后当你寻找工作时，他最终可能会成为一个重要的人脉。所以人们在收集，他们对此非常开放。但随着时间视野缩短，我们聚焦了。我们聚焦，我们品味，我们更好地看清什么重要，什么不重要。
Another change that accompanies old age and one that also appears to be driven by shortened time horizons is a shift in the kinds of information to which older people attend. Tell us more about this Laura. I think this is one of the most interesting findings. Brains do not take in information evenly,
伴随老年而来的另一个变化，似乎也是由缩短的时间视野所驱动的，那就是老年人关注的信息种类发生了转变。劳拉，请给我们多讲讲这一点。我认为这是最有趣的发现之一。大脑并不是平均地接受信息，
but rather goals direct our attention, goals direct our memories, goals direct cognitive resources. And so with colleagues of mine, Mara Mather and Susan Charles, we began to think one day about whether these changes and goals that we had documented widely in social preferences and social networks would be
而是目标引导我们的注意力，目标引导我们的记忆，目标引导认知资源。因此，我和我的同事玛拉·马瑟（Mara Mather）以及苏珊·查尔斯（Susan Charles）有一天开始思考，我们在社会偏好和社交网络中广泛记录的这些目标和变化，是否会
represented in fundamental aspects of cognitive processing. And we began to run a study which since has become widely replicated, but it was a study where we presented positive, negative, and neutral stimuli to younger middle-aged and older adults. And we had them sit in front of a computer screen and they would go through the images. And then after they've done this viewing, tell us all the images you remember. And what we find is that younger people remember almost the same numbers of positive and negative images. By middle age we see a preference and memory for the positive images and an old age that preference is whopping. That is older people
体现在认知处理的基本方面。我们开始开展一项研究，此后该研究得到了广泛的复制。这是一项我们向年轻、中年和老年成年人展示积极、消极和中性刺激的研究。我们让他们坐在电脑屏幕前，浏览这些图像。然后在这个观看过程结束后，请告诉我们你记住的所有图像。我们发现，年轻人记住的积极和消极图像数量几乎相同。到了中年，我们看到对积极图像的偏好和记忆，而在老年时，这种偏好是巨大的。也就是说，老年人
are remembering almost exclusively the positive images and they're not recalling the negative and nor the neutral ones. And so that was the first time we'd seen this. It was a little surprising to us because we weren't exactly clear why people would selectively attend to positive and not negative too because negative could be emotionally meaningful. And we thought this was super interesting. We then ran a study of autobiographical memory, again same finding, using neuroimaging, where you look at a migdala activation in response to the negative, the neutral, the positive. And again, what we see is more of a migdala activation in response to positive viewing than the viewing of negative images
几乎只记得积极的图像，他们不记得消极的，也不记得中性的。所以这是我们第一次看到这种现象。这对我们来说有点惊讶，因为我们并不完全清楚为什么人们会选择性地关注积极的而不关注消极的，因为消极的也可能具有情感意义。我们认为这超级有趣。接着我们开展了一项自传体记忆的研究，结果依然相同；我们还使用了神经成像技术，观察杏仁核对消极、中性、积极刺激的激活反应。同样，我们看到老年人在观看积极图像时，杏仁核的激活反应比观看消极图像时更多
in older people. And again, let me loop this back to some of the thinking about how negative aging was years ago. Prior to the study we did, and this was a study published in the early 2000s, but prior to that, there'd only been one study where they looked at a migdala activation in response to emotional stimuli, but the researchers had only used negative stimuli, and older people didn't remember them as well. And so the conclusion was that the amygdala's broken. I mean, there's some neural impairment. But what we showed is the amygdala's activated just fine in response to positive stimuli.
。再次说明，让我把这一点与多年前关于衰老有多么消极的一些想法联系起来。在我们开展这项研究之前——这是一项在2000年代初发表的研究——在此之前，只有一项研究观察了杏仁核对情绪刺激的激活反应，但研究人员只使用了消极刺激，而且老年人对它们的记忆没有那么好。因此得出的结论是杏仁核坏了。我的意思是，存在某种神经损伤。但我们展示的是，杏仁核对积极刺激的反应激活得非常好。
And many people, by the way, think of the amygdala as more of a salience indicator than emotion per se, right? So it's what is capturing attention, what's valuable in attention. And since then, as I say, there are now hundreds of studies showing the positivity effect. This is actually striking because, of course, there's also a wide literature across the social sciences
顺便说一句，许多人认为杏仁核与其说是一个情绪指示器，不如说是一个显著性指示器，对吧？所以它关乎什么在吸引注意力，注意力中什么是有价值的。正如我所说，自那以后，现在有数百项研究显示了积极性效应。这其实很引人注目，因为当然，社会科学领域也存在大量的文献
generally arguing that bad news is perceived more strongly than good news, right? It's sometimes called a bad news bias. But what you're saying is that really that might actually have an interesting intersection with age. Exactly. So people have long believed that negative stimuli have powerful adaptive, evolutionarily based value. And so, of course, people, and that was the way
普遍认为坏消息比好消息感知得更强烈，对吧？这有时被称为“坏消息偏见”。但你所说的其实是，这可能实际上与年龄有一个有趣的交织。完全正确。所以人们长期以来一直认为，消极刺激具有强大的、适应性的、基于进化基础的价值。因此，当然，人们——这也是这些研究的描述方式
these studies were described, people will pay more attention to negative stimuli than positive. However, people, as it turns out, were young college students and virtually all of these studies. So we were generalizing from what younger people were observed to do to humans writ large. And actually what we see now, if we look at the the body of research that has emerged since we first identified the positivity effect and cognitive processing, is that there's a gradual age
——人们会比积极刺激更关注消极刺激。然而，事实证明，所有这些研究中的受试者都是年轻的大学生。所以我们是将从年轻人身上观察到的行为泛化到了整个人类。实际上，如果我们审视自我们首次发现积极性效应和认知处理以来涌现的研究主体，我们会发现其中存在一个渐进的年龄
effect in it. And yes, younger people pay more attention to negative stimuli than positive, and then gradually that not only diminishes, but heightened attention to positive emerges. Another effect that you and other researchers have examined that looks at the effect of shrinking time horizons is how focused people are on the present versus the past or the future. Talk about this idea, Laura. There is a stereotype of older people that they live in the past and think largely about the past. There's also a literature in clinical psychology showing that when people think about the past, they're more likely to be depressed. So that kind of pattern was, you know, long believed to capture the obvious depression. We would see an older people, but of course, they're not depressed.
效应。是的，年轻人比积极刺激更关注消极刺激，随后这种现象不仅逐渐减弱，而且对积极关注的增强也随之出现。你和其他研究人员探讨过的另一个效应，着眼于缩短的时间视野的影响，那就是人们对现在的关注与对过去或未来的关注的对比。谈谈这个想法，劳拉。人们对老年人有一个刻板印象，认为他们生活在过去，主要考虑过去。临床心理学中也有文献表明，当人们考虑过去时，他们更有可能感到沮丧。因此，这种模式，你知道的，长期以来被认为捕捉到了我们在老年人身上看到的明显沮丧，但当然，他们并没有沮丧。
And here's the finding. They also don't think about the past anymore than younger people do. But they don't think about the future as much as younger people do. So younger people are rarely in a present-focused mode. They're almost always thinking about the future. Older people can actually be in the present, and that tends to be very good for mental health. There are lots of meditations now, Buddhist meditations that are intended to help people get to that present focus because living in the moment tends to take people's attention to positive aspects of the world.
这就是发现。他们并不比年轻人更多地去想过去。但他们不像年轻人那样经常去想未来。所以年轻人很少处于专注于现在的模式。他们几乎总是在考虑未来。老年人实际上可以处于现在，这往往对心理健康非常有益。现在有很多冥想，佛教冥想旨在帮助人们达到这种对当下的关注，因为活在当下往往会将人们的注意力吸引到世界的积极方面。
So in many ways, it strikes me that your focus on the effects of time horizons means that this is not really about aging in a chronological sense. It's more about the psychology of how we perceive time. Does this mean that if you experimentally induce younger people to feel like that time horizons are short, that this would then change how they feel and behave? Isn't that exciting? Yes, it does. Isn't that exciting? Yes, it does. Sarah Barber, a psychologist who works also with Mara Mother, ran a study about five years ago where they induced endings, mortality, you're approaching the end of your life, and they did this kind of imagery induction with younger people, and then presented them with stimuli, positive, negative, neutral, and younger people also showed this shift and a favoring a preference for positive information in attention and memory.
所以在很多方面，我脑海中浮现的是，你对时间视野影响的关注意味着，这其实并不是关于日历意义上的老去。它更多的是关于我们如何感知时间的心理学。这是否意味着，如果你通过实验诱导年轻人觉得他们的时间视野很短，这会改变他们的感受和行为呢？这不是很令人兴奋吗？是的，确实如此。这不是很令人兴奋吗？是的，确实如此。萨拉·巴伯（Sarah Barber）是一位也与玛拉·马瑟合作的心理学家，她在大约五年前进行了一项研究，他们向年轻人诱导结局、死亡率、你正在接近生命终点的概念，他们对年轻人进行了这种意象诱导，然后向他们展示刺激物——积极的、消极的、中性的，结果年轻人也在注意力和记忆中表现出了这种转变以及对积极信息的偏好。
What's most exciting actually about this whole line of work is we've been able, in most cases, to just lift age out of the equation and say, it's time, it's our beliefs, it's our perceptions, it's our sense of a future that affect the goals that we pursue in everyday life. I'm wondering on a college campus, whether you can see interesting differences between people who are freshmen and people who are seniors, because in some ways you almost have a natural experiment that's unfolding of people who have a sense of a long time horizon and people who have a sense of a short time horizon, at least on campus. Yes, you can compare returning sophomores to graduating seniors and their social preferences for spending time with others.
实际上，关于这一整套研究最令人兴奋的是，在大多数情况下，我们能够将年龄从等式中剔除，并说：是时间，是我们的信念，是我们的感知，是我们的未来感，影响了我们在日常生活中追求的目标。我在想，在大学校园里，你是否能看到大一新生和大四学生之间有趣的差异，因为在某种程度上，你几乎拥有了一场正在展开的自然实验：一群人对未来有长期的视野，而另一群人对未来有短期的视野，至少在校园里是这样。是的，你可以比较返校的大二学生和即将毕业的大四学生，以及他们花时间陪伴他人的社交偏好。
And as you've anticipated, the returning sophomores are interested in meeting new people and the graduating seniors are not interested in meeting new people. They're interested in spending time with their very good friends. Does the effect run in reverse as well? What happens when older people are asked to imagine that they have more time left to live? We ran an experiment where we ask exactly that question. We thought, wow, we can make young people old. Can we make old people young? And so in one study before we ask people to choose from among an array of social partners,
正如你所预料的那样，返校的大二学生对结识新朋友感兴趣，而即将毕业的大四学生则对结识新朋友不感兴趣。他们只对与非常好的朋友共度时光感兴趣。这种效应也会反过来吗？当被要求想象自己还有更多时间可活时，老年人会发生什么？我们做了一个实验，正好问了这个问题。我们想，哇，我们可以让年轻人变老。我们能让老年人变年轻吗？因此，在一项研究中，在我们要求人们从一系列社交伙伴中进行选择之前，
we said, now imagine that you just received a phone call from your physician who told you about a new medical advance that virtually insures you'll live about 20 years longer than you expected in relatively good health. Who do you choose? And now older people were no longer expressing preferences for these very well-known friends and loved ones. They were interested in exploration and novelty too.
我们说：现在想象一下，你刚接到医生的电话，他告诉你一个关于医学新进展的消息，这几乎可以确保你的寿命比预期长大约20年，而且身体相对健康。你选择谁？现在，老年人不再表达对这些非常熟知的熟人和挚爱的偏好。他们也对探索和新鲜事物感兴趣。
So I love this because in some ways what you're really identifying is sort of the underlying psychological mechanism here regardless of whether people are old or young, it does happen to be the fact that older people because they have a more limited time horizon, I'm behaving in a certain way but you can induce them to behave differently. I'm wondering once you understand this underlying psychological mechanism, what the implications of this are, are they benefits to pulling back the curtain and looking at how our sense of time left in life might be affecting us?
所以我喜欢这一点，因为在某种程度上，你真正指出的其实是这里潜在的底层心理机制，无论人们是老是少。碰巧的是，老年人因为时间视野更有限，才会表现得像那样，但你可以诱导他们表现得不同。我在想，一旦你了解了这种潜在的心理机制，它的意义是什么？拉开帷幕，看看我们对生命中所剩时间的感知可能如何影响我们，这有什么好处吗？
I believe that there are. So occasionally I'll give a talk to a largely young audience about these findings, and somebody inevitably comes up to me after the talk and says, how do I get to be more like an old person? I'd really like to be that. And then what I say is it's not a good idea, that it's adaptive to explore, to learn, and it entails taking risks, including emotional risks. But it's good to do that when you're preparing for a long future. And when you don't have to prepare for a long future, then you can focus on what really matters. So in some ways aging relieves us of the burden of the future. We can be in
我相信是有的。所以有时我会向主要是年轻人的观众发表关于这些发现的演讲，讲完后总会有人不可避免地走到我面前说：“我该怎样才能变得更像一个老年人？我真的很想那样。”然后我说这不是个好主意，探索和学习具有适应性，并且这需要承担风险，包括情感风险。但当你为漫长的未来做准备时，这样做很好。而当你不需要为漫长的未来做准备时，你就可以专注于真正重要的事情。所以从某种程度上说，衰老减轻了我们对未来的负担。我们可以身处
the moment, and that's adaptive to do that. Now, that said, it will be great if we can find ways to have younger people step out of that future-oriented mode occasionally and really experience the present. See what's positive in the world. This would be really good for them, I believe. And just the same, there are context occasions where it's really good for older people to think about the future, the long-term future, and not just the present. Think of a climate change, for example.
当下，这样做是具有适应性的。话虽如此，如果我们能找到方法让年轻人偶尔跳出那种面向未来的模式，真正体验当下，看到世界积极的一面，那就太棒了。我相信这对他们真的很有益。同样地，在某些情境下，老年人思考未来、长远未来而不仅仅是当下，也是非常好的。例如，想想气候变化。
Probably not going to affect somebody too much who's very old today, but good to pay attention to it. And so, yes, we should be able to time travel so we can step into the future or step into the present. I'm wondering whether you do this in your own life, Laura. Having done this research now, do you try and apply this? Do you actually catch yourself at various points in your day, saying, you know, here's how my time horizons are shaping
这可能不会对今天很老的人产生太大影响，但关注它是件好事。所以，是的，我们应该能够进行时间旅行，这样我们就能跨入未来或跨入现在。劳拉，我在想你是否在自己的生活中也这样做？既然已经做了这项研究，你是否尝试去应用它？你是否真的在白天的不同时刻抓住自己，对自己说，你知道，这就是我的时间视野如何塑造
how I think, and maybe I want to make that choice more mindfully? I try to take the findings to heart, and there are a couple things I do. One is something will happen to me during the day as these things happen to all of us, right? It's just really irritating or something where I just keep going over it and over it in my head again. Like, I wish I said this to someone so, you know, and what. And it really helps to put it in perspective. Like, if this were the last month of your life, would you care? And the answer is always, no. And so being able to do that, I do think helps. And then there are moments where I can get lost
我的思维的方式，也许我想更有意识地做出那个选择？我尽量把这些发现铭记于心，我做了一些事情。一是在白天会发生一些事情，正如这些事情都会发生在我们每个人身上，对吧？就是真的很烦人，或者有什么事情让我在脑海里一遍又一遍地琢磨。比如，我真希望当时对某人说了这个，等等，结果又怎样。把它放在正确的视角下真的很有帮助。比如，如果这是你生命的最后一个月，你在乎吗？答案总是“不在乎”。因此，能够做到这一点，我确实认为很有帮助。然后还有一些时刻，我可以迷失
in staring out the window of my office at home where there are a number of trees and gold finches and bush tits and blue jays. And they're're always out there and I can just stop and really just love them, you know, just love that experience. And then quickly go back and begin to think about what I have to do next and what paper is due and what email I need to return and I can go back to that. But yeah, it's good to be able to step out of the future demands occasionally. You've written that you like to think of two older people in particular. They grew up together in
在我家办公室的窗前，凝视着窗外，那里有许多树木、北美金翅雀、栗背山雀和蓝松鸦。它们总是在那里，我可以停下来，真正地爱它们，你知道的，只是去热爱那种体验。然后迅速回去，开始思考我接下来必须做什么，哪篇论文快到期了，我需要回复哪封电子邮件，我可以回到那里面去。但是，是的，偶尔能够跳出未来的需求是很好的。你曾写过你喜欢特别去想两个老年人。他们一起在
Q Gardens Hales in Queens, close friends who shared a love of music. While still in their teenage years, they started recording songs together friends who share a love of music. While still in their teenage years, they started recording songs together and they achieved a lot of success, but over time, disagreements, flared, resentments accumulated, and they mostly stopped speaking to each other. Decades later, when these two men were past 60, they elected to put their differences aside, and I want to play you a clip of them singing together. Oh. Can you imagine us years from today? Sharing appointments quietly
皇后区的邱园山谷（Q Gardens Hales）长大，是分享着对音乐的热爱的密友。在他们还是十几岁的少年时，他们就开始一起录制歌曲，并取得了巨大的成功。但随着时间的推移，分歧加剧，怨恨积聚，他们基本上不再跟对方说话了。几十年后，当这两个人都已经60多岁时，他们选择将分歧抛诸脑后，我想放一段他们一起唱歌的剪辑。哦。你能想象我们多年以后的样子吗？安静地分享约会
Up to the least strange to be sending? Oh, friends. Laura, I'm wondering what the story of Paul Simon and Art Garfunkel can tell us about friendship and forgiveness over a lifetime. I think there's something powerful to that, and I don't think it's very well understood in the science. But there is evidence that older people are more likely to forgive and that marriages improve. And this is research that comes from John Gottman and Bob Levinson and I that we did together
听起来一点也不奇怪吗？哦，朋友们。劳拉，我在想保罗·西蒙（Paul Simon）和阿特·加芬克尔（Art Garfunkel）的故事能告诉我们关于一生中的友谊和宽容的什么信息。我认为这其中蕴含着某种强大的力量，而且我认为科学界对此并没有得到很好的理解。但有证据表明，老年人更有可能原谅他人，婚姻也会改善。这是约翰·戈特曼（John Gottman）、鲍勃·莱文森（Bob Levenson）和我共同进行的研究
on older marriages, even unhappily married couples are happier as they get older. And I think some of that is they come to where the years that they weathered as a badge of honor, you know, they share something together and come to take pride in that and to begin to say, you may not be perfect, but you're mine. And there's something really moving about that. Long ago it must be I have a photograph Preserve your memories, they're all that's left here Music Psychologist Laura Carstensen works at Stanford University. Laura, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
关于老年婚姻的，即使是不那么幸福的已婚夫妇，随着年龄的增长也会更快乐。我认为其中一部分原因在于，他们把共同经受的岁月视为一种荣誉的象征，你知道的，他们共同分享了某些东西，并开始为此感到自豪，开始说：你可能不完美，但你是我的。这其中有某种真正令人感动的东西。很久以前，那一定是一张照片。保存好你的记忆，它们是这里仅存的一切。音乐。心理学家劳拉·卡斯特森（Laura Carstensen）在斯坦福大学工作。劳拉，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。
It's a pleasure. Thank you. Music is a pleasure. Thank you. If you have follow up questions for Laura Carsten sin about the signs of aging and are willing to have those questions shared with a larger hidden brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty. Please remember to include your name and a phone number where we can reach you. Again, email the question to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org and use the subject line, aging questions. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy,
不客气，谢谢。音乐。不客气，谢谢。如果你对劳拉·卡斯特森关于衰老科学的问题有后续疑问，并且愿意让这些问题与更广泛的《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，请在你的手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了。请记住附上你的名字以及我们可以联系到你的电话号码。再次强调，请将问题通过电子邮件发送至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org，并使用主题行：衰老问题。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy），
Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Odin Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is a former contributor to Hidden Brain. Dan Pink is the well-known author of many books, including most recently, The Power of Regret, how looking backward moves us forward. Dan used to be my sparring partner many years ago on a Hidden Brain
安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞恩·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥丁·巴恩斯（Odin Barnes）和安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是《隐藏的大脑》的前撰稿人。丹·平克（Dan Pink）是许多知名书籍的作者，其中包括最近的《后悔的力量：向后看如何让我们向前迈进》（The Power of Regret, how looking backward moves us forward）。许多年前，丹曾在《隐藏的大脑》的一个环节中担任我的辩论搭档，
segment we called Stop What Science. Some time ago, Dan and I were on a walk in Washington, DC, and he mentioned the work of a Stanford psychologist named Laura Carstensen. Dan isn't old, but he is an old soul. He's also an unusually generous human being. After hearing Laura explain the connections between age, wisdom, and generosity, it all makes sense to me now. Thank you, Dad. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那个环节我们叫做“停止吧科学”。不久前，丹和我一起在华盛顿特区散步，他提到了斯坦福大学一位名叫劳拉·卡斯特森的心理学家的工作。丹并不老，但他是一个饱经沧桑的灵魂。他也是一个异常慷慨的人。在听劳拉解释年龄、智慧和慷慨之间的联系后，这一切对我都说得通了。谢谢你，丹。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。